So um going to spend a few minutes just
uh finishing up the lecture from Monday.
Uh and specifically as a you know
extreme recap of what we're saying um
we started to introduce the learning
based control setting uh whereby kind of
the under underlying assumption for all
this and motivation for all this is that
we wanted to relax our assumption that
we know exactly the um the system that
we're trying to control. So we might
have even unknown dynamics or some
parameters that we wish to estimate. And
so we started essentially to introduce
on Monday kind of if you wish the
classical approaches to learning based
control where specifically we started
looking first at uh system
identification or CIS ID where the idea
of system identification is broadly
speaking let's collect a data set of
rollouts or experience in our system. uh
these might look like you know different
trajectories that we have while we
experience the evolution of our system.
Let's take this data set frame this as a
regression problem if you wish and let's
try to approximate the uh the model of
our dynamics. We saw this through the
perspective of linear regression in
particular uh but this is a general
concept where we want to approximate
some unknown dynamics from data.
We then introduced another class of
method namely adaptive control
where we looked specifically at MRAC or
model reference adaptive control where
the idea here is that we wanted to
consider the coupled system comprised of
the
controller
an adaptive component
that basically is a mechanism to
basically adapt or adjust some maybe
unknown parameters that we wish to
estimate
and the system dynamics.
So we consider this joint or coupled
system and the overall goal of adaptive
control is to study the stability of
this system and so we use leapon of
stability as our tool of reference for
measuring for estimating or analyzing
the stability. But this is loosely
speaking what we were doing. Model
reference adaptive control we saw is a
direct method where we wanted to use the
adaptive component specifically to
directly improve our controller. And the
term reference relates to the fact that
we want to adapt our controller to track
a reference signal. And now we're going
to spend maybe just a couple of slides
on mobile identification adaptive
control which is kind of another
approach that falls under the category
of adaptive control methods. But before
we get there, so just a few
clarifications on model reference
adaptive control. Uh remember that we
went through a couple of examples which
are in some way contrived from the
perspective of the analysis and
stability uh and and tools and analysis
on from the respective of stability. Uh
and we did this in kind of a mental
model was was essentially assuming that
we had you know a a few things coming in
at different stages of our analysis.
Right? So we assume that somebody was
giving us a smart way of defining the
control law U. Uh someone was giving us
a smart way of defining the the function
V. Uh the same thing for the adaptive
component. And so kind of our point here
was that in reality we would have to
come up ourselves with these components
and then you do this stability analysis.
For the purpose of this course we just
wanted to focus on showing the kind of
analysis that would come from model
reference control. [clears throat]
And so the first reference is a good one
if you want to wish if you wish to see
the kind of the forward direction. So
deriving these things
a couple of notes on the reference
signal itself. So we introduce this
reference signal as again something that
came from outside for the purpose of our
analysis. But in general if the
reference signal is very simple such as
either zero or a constant throughout
[snorts] throughout time then it is
possible that we might have many
different uh values of our parameters
that we wish to estimate that enable us
to perfectly track this reference
signal. And so in a way this uh comes
with um an identifiability issue with
respect to the actual parameters that we
wish to estimate because again here in
MRA we typically only care about the
overall performance with respect to
reference tracking and so we don't
really care necessarily about parameter
estimation.
On the other hand, if the signal is too
complex or at least complex enough such
that the only way to actually track it
is to estimate the true value of those
unknown parameters, then this creates a
problem in the sense that we or at least
it creates a tension towards caring
about parameter estimation, right?
because we and so this kind of brings up
again all our discussions that we did on
persistent exitation in the sense that
if we wish to estimate the true
parameters then we might want to um
probe the system in meaningful ways in
order to converge to the true
parameters.
Okay, any questions on this general
recap and on uh on the overall picture
here?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah, indeed it's a good point. Um
let's see. Uh well no these ones. Oh
let's quickly mention a couple of things
on uh model identification adaptive
control. Um specifically I mean the
discussion on model identification is
very case dependent because at the high
level what uh MAK is doing is basically
using system identification. So
estimating a model of our dynamics as an
inner loop for control. So what we do is
that Mayak essentially combines model
estimation with a controller that uses
this estimated model as if it was the
true one.
So in a way this is extremely
customizable because it you know you
could pick your own model that you're
trying to estimate. You you could pick
your own uh controller that uses this
model and these two things are fairly
independent the one from the other. One
distinction that typically
differentiates between uh different
methods is whether we are using kind of
working under a certainty equivalent
assumption. That is we are you know for
the purpose of modeling we assume that
uh we are estimating some parameters
theta
and these parameters theta uh are
obviously you know the goal of our uh
estimation process and so there's
uncertainty on our current estimate of
theta and so in the certainty equivalent
what we're typically assuming is that
our guess so theta hat is a point
estimate so we are currently estimating
one value of theta and we trust it
fully. On the other hand, in the
cautious approach, we are trying to
estimate a distribution over the unknown
parameters theta where the distribution
essentially is a mechanism to express
our uncertainty on the estimate itself.
So we have some data that maybe leads us
into thinking that theta hat is the more
plausible value for theta, but we have
some uncertainty on it. And so in the
cautious uh approach we're basically
trying to maintain uh these uh this
metric this estimate of uncertainty uh
and keep this also potentially for uh
for control.
So at a high level kind of mrak and mak
kind of arise from two different
perspectives. So the in MRAC the
parameters are updated directly to
minimize tracking error with respect to
our reference signal.
On the other hand in Mayak uh parameters
are updated so such as to minimize data
fitting error. So we have this
intermediate objective which is the one
of parameter estimation
and as uh we were saying my controllers
are generally more flexible because one
can couple different models and
controllers more easily. uh but at the
same time my controllers typically rely
on having a good estimate of what the
unknown parameters are. Uh and
guaranteeing kind of the performance and
stability of my controllers is typically
harder because of uh this reliance on
having to estimate the the true
parameters.
On the other hand for MRAC stability and
convergence are usually uh achieved by
by definition because we are designing
the full system such as to guarantee
stability.
Okay. And so this concludes the content
that I wanted to um discuss about
adaptive control. And so we switch into
the content for today's lecture which is
basically an introduction to imitation
learning and and reinforcement learning.
And from the perspective of our usual
road map, we are basically moving from
uh being in the top left uh quadrant
that is more classical approaches to
learning based control to the top right
where we are essentially starting to
introduce uh what I think is probably
one of the most active uh areas of
research right now when looking at um
control and autonomous systems. Uh
namely because uh there has been a push
towards end-to-end approaches and
learning based methods. uh to allow kind
of robots and autonomous systems to to
be deployed in practice.
And so in this sense um you you might
have you know stumbled and you might
have seen a lot of different videos and
you might have been following the recent
progress that is happening in robotics.
Uh at the you know there are different
reasons for for why this pro progress is
being happening. Uh one of this is
obviously the uh strong progress in the
from the perspective of foundation
models leveraging large language models
or vision language models for control.
But at the high level all of these
different end to- end pipelines that are
coming up over the last 3 to four years
are really at the end of the day being
learned through either imitation
learning or enforcement learning. So
these are the ground truth learning
signals that all of these methods and
architectures are are leveraging. And of
course their impact is not only for the
purpose of u robot manipulation. They
are being used a lot also in uh
autonomous driving. So you can see here
on the left this is a pretty recent um
uh autonomy stack from Nvidia the Alpha
Mayo which is using indeed both
imitation learning so supervised
learning and reinforcement learning to
to train part of the stack and also the
these methods namely uh reinforcement
learning are used for the alignment of
uh large language models and visual
language models nowadays where the idea
here is that we want to take these you
know large neural networks represent
large dogid models and fine-tune them to
be useful assistance and so typically
this alignment phase happens in
different ways but the main bulk of the
work is typically done through
reinforcement training in current
stacks.
So all of this to say is that these
models are these mechanisms are highly
relevant uh in uh current in current
industry and and research. uh and
therefore I think they are extremely
exciting
but for the purpose of our class what do
kind of what is the usual what is the
setting that we're interested in and
specifically kind of I would say that
basically all of the methods that we
have been focusing on so far are
essentially trying to uh define a
mechanism in which from which we can go
from some representation of the state uh
which could be more or less uh
structured to uh the definition of an
optimal control. Right? So this is
basically the gold standard that we're
aiming for when whenever we are devising
all of the methods that we looked at in
this class.
And so far I would say most of the
methods or actually all of the methods
that we have been looking at fall under
this option one category which is
basically entails having to um
acquire a deep understanding of the
problem setting. for example, in the
form of uh the an equation of the system
dynamics and then design a solution that
leverages this deep understanding of our
system. Right? You can think of indirect
methods that we looked at the beginning
of the class as the extreme canonical
example of this where we used our uh
understanding of the system to derive
optimality conditions for for control.
On the other hand, uh what the tools
we'll start to see today and for the
rest of this class uh belong to um
either option two or option three here
on the slide where at a high level we
want to set uh basically this problem of
going from a state representation to an
action as a learning problem and we'll
be doing this in two ways. So one way
will be through imitation learning where
the idea is that quote kind of um in in
some way or as the quote is seeing here
on the slides we want to learn from
demonstrations and the idea will be that
we'll be collecting data sets of
experience which are then represented as
if you want tuples of states and
decisions that were taken in those
states and we want to try to estimate
and approximate this mapping.
So in this case the demonstrations are
essentially relating to the fact that we
have an example of what is hopefully a
good behavior to take in a specific
state.
For the case of reinforcement learning
on the other hand, we want to learn by
trial and error. That is we'll be
learning from data that is uh basically
trying to pair states of we find
ourselves in with a score or metric that
basically tells us how good a specific
action or control is in that state. So I
hope that you're seeing already the kind
of philosophical distinction between
these two approaches because on one hand
we have a teacher that tells us what is
a good action to take. On the other
hand, for the case of reinforcement
learning, we don't have uh an entity
that tells us what is a good behavior to
take, but we have a measure that tells
us how good a specific action is. And so
the overall goal of reinforcement
learning will be to try out different
strategies and figure out which one is
the most rewarding in practice.
>> Yes. when you're doing this might be
sort of question what you're doing.
>> Is the data that you're feeding into
your algorithm always going to be
treated as like the perfect model or is
there a way to inform the algorithm
you're working with this is an example
of something good but it could be done
better.
>> [clears throat]
>> M yeah this is a good question and I
think it touches on I would say one of
the main u limitations if you wish of
imitation learning because at at face
value imitation learning assumes that
the mapping that you're trying to
approximate from your data is actually
representative of good solutions right
so here in a way imitation learning is
kind of bounded by the performance of
the behaviors that you have your data um
this is a statement that you know has
you know an asterisk in a way because
there are different ways of
instantiating the imitation learning
problem to maybe uh favor uh high
performance behavior with respect to
others in the data set. Um but in
general this is the case where uh your
performance that you can get out of your
data is typically bottlenecked by the
performance of your teacher if that
makes sense.
>> Yeah. Yes.
learning to learn like like the basics I
guess and then move to reinforcement
learning to like tune it more like it's
easier to make it possible once you know
you're completely.
>> Yeah. So this is one of the points we'll
be doing in a few slides from now. Uh
but the idea is that I would say current
autonomy stacks and kind of the training
of current autonomy stacks is typically
a layered process where you have
different phases of training. uh I would
say this has been inherited mostly by
the large language model community and
the NLP community where these things
these large models have stages of
training. So you have maybe a vast
pre-training stage where you're just
learning how to you know the system and
general rules of the world and then
you're trying to distill more and more
high quality data in along the way and
so usually yes I think you have a good
intuition where supervised learning and
imitation learning could be a way to get
a good starting point and then
reinforcement learning could be used to
fine-tune. Yeah.
Okay. And so in this context what we'll
be doing today is we'll start by just
fixing kind of our notation
understanding on supervised learning and
then we'll go into kind of a discussion
on imitation learning and reinforcement
learning where the idea for today is to
basically
fixate and understand I would say the
fundamentals of what imitation learning
and reinforcement learning are in
general kind of the distinction and
similarities between these two
approaches and how they relate with each
other. So I would say at a high level uh
I I think that you should see this
lecture as trying to build a mental
model of how these different tools are
organized and should be seen. Um and in
the following weeks starting on Monday
we'll then start to actually introduce
concretely different methods that belong
to these uh to these families.
And of course as I said this is one of
the most active areas of research right
now. So there are plenty of great um
references out there. uh apart from the
textbook uh from the class definitely
the Saturn embarto for reinforcement
learning is a is a great reference and
there are also a number of classes both
here at Stanford for example DRL uh and
the kind of equivalent on it in at
Berkeley
but so starting from supervised learning
I would say in general uh supervised
learning described this tasks where uh
where we want to learn a mapping here
represent denoted as f on the slides
from some input set X to an output set
uh Y. And this represents kind of a
general formalism where most kind of
regression and for example
classification tasks can be uh
understood.
For example, uh we might want to learn
an image classifier. So something that
maps from images of animals or uh
different scenes to a class category of
the object that is present in that
scene. And so here in this case the
mapping would essentially be learning in
this function that takes an input X here
represented for example as an RGB image
to the class that represents the object
present in that image. But more
generally this is uh essentially the
problem of learning a mapping that goes
from some input representation denoted
usually as a vector X to an output
representation which could also be
another vector Y.
And when we say learning this typically
involves uh data in the form of input
output pairs so xy and we want to
approximate this mapping uh by uh
typically kind of methods along the
lines of maximum likelihood estimation
and to um really set down the notation
we'll be using going forward let us go
quickly through a simple example. So
consider this uh simple regression where
we have some input data X uh and some
output data Y and we have some examples
and examples of these mappings
represented by the red dots here on the
slide. Our problem in the in this case
supervised learning problem might be
essentially trying to fit uh a candidate
kind of parabolic function to this data.
And so in this case our mapping that we
wish to learn will be a parametric
function f of theta with parameters
theta. And the supervised learning
problem will be to learn these
parameters theta that minimize some
notion of of error. And so we saw this
last time already could be for example
in the form of minimizing some squared
error loss.
Of course equivalently this can be
written from the perspective of
maximizing likelihood. So instead of
seeing this as an error minimization
when we want to minimize the discrepancy
between our predictions and the actual
uh realizations of some mapping that we
wish to estimate um we might be positing
this as a probabilistic learning problem
where our function might we basically
hypothesize that our data is distributed
according to some uh distribution. For
example, here the probability of a point
Y given X might be represented by a
Gaussian distribution where our function
could represent the mean of this gausian
distribution given some known uh
variance. So pictorially here is as if
we were placing some you know small
gausians on top of each point and the
overall learning problem will be to
maximize the joint probability of all
our uh data points.
And so learning through maximum like
through likelihood maximization can be
written as basically taking the argmax
of the product of all the uh conditional
uh probability distributions of our
observed data yis given our prediction f
of x i
mathematically this is uh typically not
very well behaved object because we have
the product of a bunch of terms that are
between zero and one and so what people
do in practice This is that rather than
maximizing the likelihood we would tend
to minimize the negative log likelihood.
So we are taking the logarithm of this
and the logarithm is a monotonic
transformation. So it basically
preserves the uh the extrem points. So
the maximum are preserved. So in
practice you know you would go from a
situation where maybe the uh your
maximum likelihood point would be with a
very narrow or peaked. So this is the
objective function that we wish to
maximize. If we take the so this would
be the
maybe the probability of given x. If we
take the log of this this would
typically boil down to basically
smoothing out uh this uh this uh loss
function uh landscape while preserving
the the same point. So this might be the
same uh mu hat for example.
Okay, but this is uh I hope this is uh
mostly repetition and uh and background
for for most of you guys.
So, but why do we care about um about
supervised learning and the point is
that supervised learning as we will see
is basically the cornerstone of uh
imitation learning. And this is because
imitation learning essentially refers to
uh a class of methods that enable uh
skills to be transferred from an expert
to a learner. And in the context of
robotics, this expert is typically a
human operator or some pre-existing uh
control policy. And the learner is
basically our policy that we wish to uh
approximate. Right? So in this case you
could think as um basically we have this
uh bimmanual
uh manipulation system where we have a
human teleoperator that is controlling
this robot. And so for us the human kind
of logging these uh actions would be the
teacher or the kind of the the skilled
expert. We would then be collecting
these data sets of controls that the
humans is taking and then the learning
problem will then be basically figuring
out how to map from the states of this
manual uh by by manual manipulator to
the controls. So basically minimizing
for example the error with respect to
what the humans would have done in that
case.
And so imitation learning uh at a high
level assumes access to a data set as we
were saying before of essentially pairs
of states X and controls U uh that are
corrected by collected by observing some
some expert that is uh behaving in the
world and imitation learning should be
interpreted as an umbrella term that
broadly speaking u
comprehends two families of approaches.
The first one is behavior cloning that
is in a way also the most intuitive of
the two whereby in behavior cloning what
we want to learn or at least the goal of
learning is directly learning this
policy that maps from states to
controls. So in behavior cloning our
kind of objective of learning will be to
learn a parametric representation of our
policy pi that basically minimizes some
some notion of error between the uh true
x and new pairs that we have in our data
set and the one we are predicting.
The other class of methods is known as
reinforcement learning or also often
known as inverse optimal control where
on the other hand
the objective here is to approximate the
reward or objective that the expert is
currently optimizing. So in some way the
main goal or output of an inverse
reinforcement learning algorithm will be
to estimate a reward function R that
maps pairs of states and controls to a
measure of success or performance.
So you see how these two families and
categories of approaches are in a way
nicely complimentary to each other
because here we're directly
approximating the mapping that leads us
from uh states to controls. Well, here
we're approximating the kind of
objective that we think the expert is
optimizing and then use this for
control.
>> Yes. So
that means
>> a [clears throat] policy for like for
example if I'm picking up something like
back out the policy for what I'm
thinking kind of.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So it would be as if
maybe I don't know like an example could
be
in a navigation task, right? So say we
have some task where we have a starting
point here and like a goal point here.
Uh in the behavioral cloning route we
would be collecting examples of
trajectories of how to get to the goal
and we would be imitating those. In the
case of inversion learning, what we
might be interested in doing on the
other hand is learning maybe a sort of
vector field where the cost is basically
lower at the goal state and increases
uh in other states, right? So it's
basically something that tells us how to
behave in that sense from the
perspective of the util operation. Yes,
this is what you were saying.
Yeah,
I guess inverse reinforcement learning
you still have to be optimization to
find the best control given the current
state like some
>> Yes. Yes, indeed. So at the end of the
day, this is not something that
practically leads to a rule of how to
behave. So there will be an additional
step which is having to derive a policy
that optimizes this objective. But this
is something that we have many tools to
to do, right?
um
maybe to give you some understanding to
when inversion reinforcement learning
might be useful. So take the example of
maybe learning how to drive autonomous
driving right um it is I would say hard
to specify numerically what good driving
means. First of all it's hard in general
but also because every each and every
one of us has a different interpretation
of what good driving means. And so in
this way what we would be doing is would
be collecting
examples of people driving. And this is
actually easy to collect because we just
let people drive. And then from that you
would be deriving a sort of analytical
expression that tells us what these
people thought it was relating with good
with good driving and then optimize for
that.
Okay. And so looking at the first of the
two, so behavior cloning, um I would say
the main idea of behavior cloning is in
some way particularly simple. So the
main idea is that we want to train a
policy through supervised learning. So
the skeleton of an imitation learning
algorithm typically goes that we have a
data set of expert demonstrations.
Again, we have someone teleoperate our
our robot
and then we basically just train our
policy to mimic this expert through any
of our favorite uh kind of supervised
learning methods, right? So maybe
minimizing or doing maximum likelihood
estimation on that data set.
And uh I would say one of the very first
examples of working behavior cloning in
practice dates back to the late 1980s.
Um, if I remember correctly, this is a
study from uh CMU. And the goal here was
to basically learn how to drive from uh
examples of of uh of humans driving. So
there was this military vehicle and the
problem that they set up was in some way
kind of resembling to what I would say
mo many of the also recent approaches
are doing. So they're basically
recording some images, maybe a front
camera images on the vehicle or other
cameras around the vehicles and they're
try basically mapping those cameras to
the steering angle for for the vehicle
in spec and specifically at the time
they were doing this by learning a small
neural network to to do this. And you
know for for the times this was actually
a pretty amazing result because they got
the the vehicle to drive on fairly easy
roads and controlled environments. uh
but still kind of this I think
kind of really maps out also kind of
this the skaton of what many of the most
current methods are doing that is trying
out to to set the behavior cloning
problem as something that goes from a
highdimensional input for example image
space to a control that we care about
and so you might ask like you know this
was happening in the 1980s 1990s so is
this all that there is to it to
imitation machine learning or is there
is there more? And in particular, is
this simple recipe guaranteed to work?
And the spoiler is of course no. There
are a number of of details that that
come with uh with these uh techniques.
And I would say the main factor here is
that imitation learning is fundamentally
different from plain supervised learning
for a number of different ways.
Specifically, we saw before how
supervised learning at its core is
basically a mechanism to learn a mapping
from input data to output labels based
on a data set of examples of this
mapping.
On the other hand, imitation learning
while it does build heavily on or
specifically uh behavior cloning builds
heavily on supervised learning, it has
some key differences. And specifically
one is that in the case of deploying an
autonomous system in the real world,
even small prediction errors will
compound over time, right? And so you
can imagine a situation where
we have uh maybe a data set that was
showing us a certain behavior of our
system, right? So going from x0 taking
uh u 0, x1,
u1 and so forth.
At deployment time, if we were to start
from the same X0,
regardless of how good our model is, we
there will always going to be most
likely some prediction error, right? And
so maybe this will lead us into defining
kind of a U0 hat that is slightly
different from the original U0, which
leads us to a slightly different X1.
And now we are in a way that is you know
in in a state that is potentially
slightly outside of the support of our
data distribution which will lead to
having a following prediction that is
even slightly more off. Right? And so
you can see how this compounding effect
is basically getting exponentially worse
over time. Right? Because we are since
in the context of autonomous systems and
imitation learning we are active agents
in the environment. Our errors will lead
to denote um kind of the distribution of
states that we observe
and this is something that is not
present in in plain supervised learning.
Another reason for does this make sense?
Yeah.
So another reason for for why imitation
learning is also a difference is that in
general since here we're we might be
dealing with physical systems. There
might be some physical constraints or
dependencies that are that are basically
unique to the fact that we're dealing
with some real world embodied system.
Right? So if you're just learning a
mapping from camera images to uh object
classes, then we literally have no
limits to what those object classes uh
can be within that vocabulary. On the
other hand, if we're trying to learn to
predict the joint angles of a robot
manipulator, we have some constraints
that we have to adhere to, right? So we
cannot output any joint angle
along this line. in in general the
domain the source domain may may
different from the one we have at
deployment. So say that we are trying to
learn how to control a humanoid by
looking at videos of humans doing
different uh different actions. There is
of course an embodiment gap
and I would say kind of most of these
problems boil down to uh what is known
as coari shift and we'll talk more about
this on on Monday but the idea is that
the state distribution that is induced
that is observed through the expert by
state distribution I mean the set of
states that we are observing while kind
of seeing the expert behave will be
different from the set of states that
we're observing as we ourselves are
taking decisions.
And so this leads to a a distribution
shift that is uniquely not there in the
plain supervised learning setting. And
last but not least, if collecting more
data of images might be extremely cheap,
we just scrape the internet. Collecting
demonstrations or useful demonstrations
in the case of robotics is usually quite
more expensive because you have to maybe
drive your car around.
Okay. And so on Monday we'll basically
start looking at these challenges and
mechanism to uh to approach them.
Any any questions so far?
Okay.
So let's also say a couple of words on
inverse reinforcement learning. So as we
were saying before in inverse
reinforcement learning uh we should
basically see this as an orthogonal
approach to imitation learning uh where
we are trying to recover our reward
function from de demonstrations of a
policy right and as an example this just
to to ground the intuition we could for
example consider the fact where we have
a warehouse robot that must navigate
from a starting point to a goal point
similar to what we're saying here And in
the case of behavior cloning, we would
be collecting demonstrations of uh
examples of how to go from A to B uh and
then train a policy that can imitate
that behavior. Now, this policy will
probably be quite effective in similar
scenarios. For example, going from the
same state and goal uh combination, but
in the moment where we might be maybe
reassembling the configuration of the uh
of the warehouse, then this might find
some uh some limitations. On the other
hand, if we understand the overall goal
of the expert from which we have um
demonstrations, then we have a basically
a representation in this case the reward
function that can be potentially much
more generalizable.
For example, something along the lines
of moving closer to the goal is good and
moving closer to the obstacles is is
bad, right? something that is can be
seen as a sort of vector field in the
space of a possible path.
Now this is not to say that reinforce
reinforcement learning is generally
better uh but just to highlight a
potential kind of dissimilarity between
these two these two methods
and we will see again kind of a number a
couple of specific instantiations of
reinforce reinforcement learning.
Okay. So let's now introduce um some key
terminology and notation for uh for
reinforcement learning.
And
at a high level kind of fundamentally I
would say that reinforcement learning
can be seen as a formalism for learning
based decision-m where it is basically
an approach for learning how to make
decisions from from experience and this
happens by basically following a basic
learning loop an interaction between two
agents. The first one is uh what our
policy or here referred to as the agent
and then we have an environment which is
basically the world we are or our system
that we're interacting with and the
interaction between these two elements
usually goes such that we have the agent
observing some state. The agent will
take the state in order to compute an
action or control UT. This action will
be kind of acted on the in the
environment which on the other hand will
return to us with a an updated state of
the system and a scalar measure of
performance our reward RT. And if you
see this loop kind of unrolling over
time. This leads to the definition of a
trajectory to which is nothing else than
the kind of unrolled sequence of states
and controls and rewards that we are
observing over time.
And the point in reinforcement learning
is that basically all reinfor
reinforcement learning algorithms out
there will basically use these um
trajectories in order to improve the
policy.
And so when we were we're referring to
as learning by trial and error, this is
what we meant because we reinforcement
learning essentially defines this uh
interaction where we have an agent that
is an active agent in our system tries
out different strategies and will use
the trajectories that result from its
exploration to maximize some notion of
score and performance.
And so in reinforcement learning
literature which generally originates
from the computer science uh literature
there are a number of terminologies that
I think uh is good to to set in place.
So we'll refer to as policy as a mapping
from state to actions. Uh that basically
defines the agents behavior and this
typically is expressed at least in the
area literature as a distribution over
controls given states.
So so far we were mostly assuming that
the policy was a deterministic policy.
So something that basically led to
a control given a state. But in the RL
literature, this is usually seen as a
distribution over
uh over controls given states.
So in practice,
if we have our kind of grid world
example for navigation, our possible
actions might be, you know, the four
cardinal directions.
And in this case the policy will then be
representing
uh a distribution over
these four cardinal directions right in
the case of a discrete action space in
this case.
Similarly, if we were um
representing a continuous action space,
we could potentially use a gausian
distribution, right?
Over candidate action z.
Okay. When we refer to as environment,
we will basically refer to as the system
the agent interacts with.
Mathematically, this is represented as a
again conditional distribution over the
next states given the current states and
the current actions.
The reward is a scalar measure of
immediate success. So something that
lead gives us that given a state and a
control will give us a scalar measure of
how good that control was in that
specific state.
And we will be very often talking about
uh value functions. So if on one hand
the year reward measures immediate
success. So again how good was this
action in a specific state
a value function represents a measure of
performance in the long run. That is
specifically it will define how much the
agent can expect to achieve in the
future. So I would say again visually um
say that we have our usual kind of p
pictorial trajectory here kind of the
reward function is something that is
defined over the immediate transition.
So given a state and a control [snorts]
but at this state depending on the
uncertainty that might come from the
policy. So here we might sample
different actions or the state
transition might also be stoastic. So
given the same action we might also end
up in different states. So there is if
you wish like a whole set of possible
evolutions of the state that we could
have. So the value function is something
that is interested in the expected value
of the reward that we that we can expect
to have given uh policy.
And the reason why I would say basically
most or almost all the algorithms in
reinforcement learning really focus a
lot on the estimating value functions is
because this is really the uh kind of
the golden standard that we wish to work
with when taking decision right we don't
really care about immediate success most
likely but we care about the overall
success of uh in our task.
Does this make sense?
And optionally, we'll be talking about
models. Namely, the models for the agent
will essentially be representing its
understanding of the environment or for
us, it will be basically an approximate
model of the of the system dynamics,
right? Mathematically this will be
represented as also a distribution over
next states given current states and
current actions but this will basically
represent our understanding of the
environment. [snorts] This model might
is might be learned namely we might
choose or not to approximate this this
model meaning we might want to design a
strategy that leverages this approximate
understanding of our environment or
simply choose to ignore it. And so in
the case of reinforcement learning, this
is basically what differentiates between
what are called as model free
reinforcement learning algorithms and
model based reinforcement learning
algorithms.
Okay. But then the question is why
should we uh go for reinforcement
learning and what are the kind of
redeeming characteristics of of these
techniques? And I would say one clear
kind of winner in terms of reinforcement
learning for me is the fact that u
reinforcement learning can discover new
and unexpected solutions. So along the
lines of what your colleague was also
alluding to in the case of imitation
learning we're basically at least in
principle bounded by the quality of the
demonstrations that we have. Right? So
we're basically trying to distill some
knowledge or behavior that we think is
good enough or optimal in the form of a
learned mapping by trying to approximate
this mapping explicitly. In
reinforcement learning, we want to
discover what are good solutions by
maximizing some notion of performance.
And so this is potentially unbounded by
any teacher simply because there is no
teacher, right? And so I think a good
example here is you know kind of some of
the most recent successes in
reinforcement learning started uh in the
mid2010s
uh with uh kind of game playing.
And here the uh agent was essentially
trying to to solve this this pong game
in the Atari family. And you know it
started basically trying around
different strategies. At the beginning
it was not that good. But then by where
the goal here was essentially to um
learn how to control this while trying
to maximize the score as a notion of
reward. But then over over time by
basically trying out different
strategies is it was starting to become
more and more professional
until I think after some time kind of
the interesting aspect that turned out
is that the model kind of found an
interesting strategy which is basically
the one of digging a tunnel here on the
side of the screen. uh because it turned
out that this is an optimal way to or a
very smart way to easily get a lot of
points, right? And so um this is
obviously in the case of games. Uh but
you might have heard about one of the
you know famous successes of
reinforcement training is the case of
Alph Go where it basically there was a
model trained to play the game of Go. uh
and it ultimately you know defeated the
world champions Liido in a in a in a
famous in a famous match and there was
this move 37 I really advise you to
check there's a full documentary on this
about about this uh this project where
move 37 was one that really stunned even
most of the experts that couldn't really
have would have never thought about this
uh this this uh this move and so this is
really what I mean by discovering ing
new solutions because here we're only
we're not really bounded by
demonstrations but we are in the case of
reinforcement learning trying to
maximize some some notion of score.
Another reason for why I think
reinforcement learning is particularly
powerful is that reinforcement learning
algorithms are very effective at
optimizing complex objectives or kind of
complex reward functions definitions.
Um and this makes it appealing for
complex physical tasks. So in this case
uh you know doing locomotion of a
quadriped on rough terrain is an
extremely hard problem to solve through
maybe analytical tools or kind of
optimal optimization based control
tools. But on the other hand,
reinforcement turning is now I would say
the de facto standard for uh basically
robot locomotion because you can
basically leverage these highly
paralyzable simulation environments. Let
the the robots learn how to navigate in
these environments um without having to
rely on assumptions on contact dynamics
and trying to estimate the models of of
your system and so forth. And so this is
really a field where reinforcement
learning is turning out to be extremely
extremely powerful.
>> Yes.
>> Having to kind of model the contact
dynamics anyway for the model that gets
trained in.
>> Uh so the simulator internally is you
know is a physics based simulator. So
they do have some uh some at the very
least very accurate model of the of the
physics. uh but these might be very
expensive right so here you're basically
trying to distill these uh this physics
knowledge into a policy so the policy
itself is just a neuron net right that
basically maps inputs to outputs most
likely um and it's not really taking
into account the physics but it's
learned them implicitly through the
simulator if it makes sense
when you deploy it it's just a yes
exactly
And so when we look at reinforcement
learning um I think it's nice to
highlight how it it is different from
other machine learning uh paradigms. So
first of all we highlighted this
already. So in reinforcement learning we
don't have a supervision signal right we
only have a reward function. There is
nobody that teaches us what is a good ex
uh action to take. We only have a
measure that tells us
how good is an action we try to take.
In general, depending on the task,
feedback can be delayed. Um, take the
example of learning how to play chess
through reinforcement learning. It is
kind of hard to give credit to one
specific move in a chess game until we
reach the end. Right? So we actually
what we actually the the only grounded
reward signal that we get is whether we
win or not the game. But then
accrediting this to any specific moves
becomes challenging. And so this is what
I mean by delayed rewards which creates
this problem of credit assignment which
is one of the fundamental problems in
reinforcement learning. And so we'll see
how different algorithms basically try
to approach this through the notion of
value functions most likely.
And then we also hinted at this uh
briefly but in reinforcement learning
data is not uh iid. So the iid
assumptions I would say is one of the
most fundamental assumptions in
statistical learning theory. Basically
any theorem out there assumes that the
data is uh independent and identically
distributed and we can basically sample
from the same data generation process.
However, when we work with reinforcement
learning, we are indeed in this setting
where the actions we take now influence
the states we will see in the future,
right? And so this clearly breaks this
assumption because the data is not
independent.
And so this creates for typically much
more instable learning uh problems. And
many of the algorithms that we will see
uh in the next week essentially will
have some mechanism in order to
regularize uh the learning problem
partially also because of this uh
misalignment.
Formally reinforcement learning kind of
builds on top of the formalism of markup
decision processes which we introduced
before and specifically we I would say
here is where it's also important that
you all build kind of a uh plasticity in
dealing with different notation because
uh until now we have been following the
notation that comes from the optimal
control literature for example states
are x and controls are u But in the
reinforcement learning literature, this
typically builds out from the computer
science community which applies just a
different notation for the same objects.
Right? So uh instead of being x's and u
for example in reinforcement learning
you will most likely be finding states
as s and actions as a um but in general
in order to be consistent throughout
this course we will keep dealing with uh
the denotation that comes from the
controls community. And so we'll be
defining a state space X uh that belongs
to kind of calligraphic X. State space
is just the state the the set of states
that we can be in. Again take this
navigation uh example. This would be all
of the cells where we could be in. Same
thing for the actions. This could be a
set all the set of all possible actions
that we can take in our environment.
Uh we have a transition function or
dynamics. Usually in the RL community,
this is expressed as a conditional
distribution. So the distribution over
next states given current states and
controls. We'll have a reward function
as we discussed before and we will have
a discount factor which is used as a
mathematical trick if you wish to um
highlight how much we care about
uh immediate reward against long-term
reward.
So I think this is more clearly
explained here in this uh in this
objective
where specifically given a mark of
decision process that is typically
expressed as a uh tupole of elements.
The goal of reinforcement turning will
be to maximize the RL objective which is
the expected reward future reward or
specifically the expected discounted
future reward under the trajectory
distribution. Now what is this
trajectory distribution? Loosely
speaking this is nothing else than the
distribution over all possible
trajectories that we could ever observe.
Again kind of along the lines of what
we're saying here, we have some
environment with which we're interacting
with. The trajectory distribution is a
distribution that assigns probability to
each and every one of these possible
trajectories.
Mathematically, this is uh derived uh
through these uh conditional
independencies. So the probability over
a trajectory to is basically the
probability of starting from an initial
state x0
multiplied by the product of basically
the two sources of randomness that we
have where one is just the randomness
over the next state and one is the
randomness given by our policy.
So given this trajectory distribution
the RL objective will be to maximize the
discounted sum of rewards
the expected sum of discounted sum of
rewards where the expectation is taken
under this trajectory distribution.
The discounting here as you might notice
is basically
a mechanism for which we can give more
or less weight to immediate or future
rewards.
Also mathematically this is something
that allows us to deal with infinite
horizon problems because if this were to
be an infinite sum then you know good
luck optimizing this. Uh but if we have
this uh scalar uh discount factor then
this actually becomes tractable.
Any questions on uh on this uh
formulation?
Okay.
And so I would say whenever you will be
setting up also in your pet sets um some
reinforcement learning problems, I think
kind of the very first uh decision to
take will be to basically uh define what
an MDP is for our problem. And so some
examples here take the case of chess.
The state base might be uh defined by
all the possible positions of the pieces
on the board. The actions will be
basically all the feasible next moves.
Uh the dynamics here are deterministic.
So given a position of the board and a
action then the next state will just be
the conse the next position of pieces on
the board. uh and the reward function
might be something as simple as negative
one if we lose the game or plus one if
we win the game.
Similar thing for a quadriped.
The state might be the robot's pose and
we might be controlling kind of the
joint torque commands for each of the
legs of the quadripeds. And then the
dynamics here might be kind of where we
think these the the quadroet will be
given uh some specific choice of of
torqus. And the reward function if we
wish for the quadro to basically learn
how to walk fast it will be something as
you know a positive if we're taking a
forward step uh something negative if
we're falling and then uh kind of zero
if we're still standing but again these
are just toy examples but the the the
intuition here is that whenever we posit
our problem as a reinforcement learning
problem we will have to necessarily
define the elements that define uh an
MDP
Okay. And so we mentioned before how
value functions are really key in
defining uh reinforcement learning
algorithms. So we will often be dealing
with different versions of or different
instantiations of the concept of a value
function. Specifically, let's start from
I would say the most intuitive one which
is the state value function also
expressed as uh B of X which kind of um
intuitively represents the expected
total reward that we expect the agent to
have if we start in a specific state and
act according to a particular policy. So
first of all let's note that the value
functions are conditioned on a specific
policy. Right? So the future values that
we expect to have depend inherently on
how we think we will behave. Right? So
the value function is an object that
depends on a policy.
In particular, the state value function
is a
concept that relates with a specific
state. So in this case the value
function of state X1 will essentially be
the expectations of all my discounted
rewards that I expect to have given the
well the uncertainty of the environment
itself but also the uncertainty that
comes from the current policy that I'm
following.
Similarly, the action state value
function also known as Q function is on
the other hand something that still
measures this expected future total
reward. But this time is not only uh uh
something that depends on the state but
it depends on the state and the action
that we take in that state. So it will
be essentially the expected to the
reward that we expect the agent to
observe. If we start in a state, take an
action and then act according to a
particular policy.
Now you might think that the distinction
here is not too drastic. Seems as they
are basically approximating the same
thing apart from the uncertainty on the
one-step action. But can you think of a
reason why Q functions might be in a way
more practical for the purpose of of
control?
>> Yes.
current policy.
>> Sorry.
>> If you want to explore outside your
current policy,
>> uh what do you mean by that?
>> Policy is right.
>> Mhm.
>> DV
in that sense. Yes, I agree. So I think
you're capturing something that will be
we'll discussing it on
uh next week Wednesday. I think
specifically in value based methods uh
when we we talk about off policy
algorithms here this will be the
mechanism through which we can basically
try actions that do not depend on our
policy so in this way yes uh but this is
not exactly what I was referring to here
any other any other ideas
>> is it something along the lines of it
allows you to predict for like the next
move like if you're playing chess it's
not just like is is moving my knight
here going to put me in a good position
for my knight? It's like how will this
set up the board?
>> Mhm. Yes, I think you're capturing
exactly the the point here in the sense
that uh ultimately what we care about is
having a mechanism to choose what our
next action is. If we can estimate the u
optimal act Q function meaning the the
value function that represents what the
future estimate of my cost is for the
optimal function. I basically have uh
a function that I can easily basically
optimize over. Right? So basically I
could taking an action would basically
entail doing an Rmax over my Q function.
Right? So here is something where
imagine that this is just a lookup
table. I have an object that for each
state and each action gives me an
estimate of what the future reward is.
Right? So basically what I could do is I
could basically iterate over all
possible actions in that state and then
pick the one with the highest uh value.
And so these basic Q functions are
critical because they give us a
practical mechanism through which uh to
learn how to behave.
Does this make sense?
Okay. And so we so here we are saying
how the value functions depend on a
specific policy
because of this value functions follow a
specific ordering. So there is a partial
ordering across value functions right.
So depending on um how good the policy
is then a value function could be grow
kind of greater or smaller than uh than
others. And so we can define the concept
of optimal uh state value functions and
Q functions as basically the value
functions that uh relate with the policy
that makes for the maximum expected uh
reward.
And these optimal state value function
and Q functions are basically the golden
standard we would be ideally aiming to
and what most of the algorithms try to
converge to because once you have this
the optimal Q function then picking the
optimal action is basically entails
doing an argmax over Q.
And so again we'll dig into details next
week. uh but in general I I definitely
advise you to fixate these concepts in
your in your mind because these are
really kind of at the the foundation of
I would say most reinforcement learning
algorithms out there
and so we mentioned kind of
reinforcement learning algorithms you
know as a plural because there are many
of them and in general RL algorithms can
be differentiated in a number of
subasses. So the first distinction we
already mentioned it it basically
divides model free from model based
algorithms. So are we using the dynamics
or are we interested in using dynamics
known or approximate for our algorithms
or are we just not interested in them.
So we try to learn a policy without even
trying to approximate our dynamics.
Within the model free algorithms, we
will see policy optimization methods
which basically are algorithms that try
to directly optimize for the RL
objective that we introduced before. So
we will see how we are going to try to
directly cast the RL problem as a
maximization of the RL objective
and then we will have value based
methods which on the other hand will
basically optimize for this objective
implicitly. So we won't be doing facing
this taking this at face value but we
will be trying to estimate the optimal
value functions and then defining our
policy pi as an argmax over the optimal
value function.
On the other side of the spectrum in
modelbased algorithms we will either try
to estimate the model so we don't know
what the dynamics are but so we try to
estimate it along the lines of system
identification and then use these
estimate models to improve our policies
or we might just know the model and then
this basically boils down to many of the
tools we saw in the previous weeks in
this class.
And so you might ask yourself kind of
why so many reinforcement learning
algorithms? Kind of how do we even
navigate choosing between different
reinforcement learning algorithms? And I
would say the reality is that there are
a number of trade-offs. So we'll talk a
lot about sample efficiency and
stability. So by sample efficiency means
how many interactions with the
environment do I have to do before I
actually converge to something that is
useful. And so we will see how different
algorithms will be more or less sample
efficient.
Typically
we also see how different algorithms are
more or less stable. So uh is it easier
to learn how to estimate the optimal
value function or is it easier to
directly optimize for the RL objective
and so different algorithms will be in
different side of the spectrums here. Of
course also the assumptions in our
environment will play a role. So are we
in an episodic setting that is can we
easily restart our chess game or are we
in an infinite horizon setting where
there are no resets and so depending on
this what is the right algorithm
are we dealing in a kind of with a
continuous state or action space or a
discrete one right so more different
algorithms will be more or less um
tailored for these cases and then I
would say more fundamentally when we
talk about model based methods is it
easier to represent the policy directly
or is it easier to represent the model
or again doing a simple example take
kind of the case where we're trying to
balance uh a pole the usual cart pole
example right where we want to keep this
pole upright by controlling the cart.
Now if we wish wanted to estimate the an
approximate model of our system dynamics
kind of this depending on where the pole
is might be an extremely non kind of a
nonlinear model to approximate right
well and so potentially difficult. On
the other hand if we simply look at how
to behave the behavior rule is not that
hard to encode. Right? So if the pole is
going left, I might also want to go left
to counterbalance for that movement. If
the pole is going, you know, I kind of
controlling the pole the cart based on
the position of the pole is actually a
pretty easy thing to do.
Or a more mundane, you know, whenever
we're all taking a shower, we don't
really model the thermodynamics of where
the heat uh propagation is and how the
heat and the water is propagating to our
body, but simply we feel something is
hot and we turn the knob, right? So that
is actually easier to control compared
to estimating the full model of the
system.
And with sample efficiency, we'll look
at off policy and off and on policy
algorithms. We'll see how there is a
spectrum of algorithms from the less
efficient to the more efficient.
And so the question there could be why
even bother using less efficient
algorithms? And the point is that wall
clock time is not the same as
efficiency. So typically more kind of
less sample efficient algorithms are
also the ones that are more stable. And
so if we are in a setting where we can
easily paralyze or simulate in a cheap
way then we don't really need to go
through the effort of having complex and
unstable algorithms because of
efficiency. But actually we can use less
efficient algorithms. Uh but because for
us experience is very cheap
and we'll look at different kind of
stability and convergence properties of
of different methods.
But so to um to conclude so I one thing
that I want you all to take out of this
of this lecture today is that so we have
been introducing and hopefully building
this mental model in which we can
navigate uh different algorithms
starting next week and but I don't want
that the key takeaway here is that
algorithms in belonging into different
buckets should be seen as alternatives
specifically I don't want that uh
imitation learning and reinforcement
learning are seen seen as alternatives.
So along the lines of what your
colleague was alluding to before, I
would say that nominally kind of uh
frontier uh pipelines and architectures
for autonomous systems typically rely
more and more on end to end frameworks.
So these tools are more and more used.
So there is a lot of uh learning going
on. But this learning is not done in
either through imitation learning or
through reinforcement learning. But
typically frontier uh pipelines and
autonomy stacks are essentially built as
scaffolded training pipelines whereby
different algorithms and different
techniques play roles at different
elements of the stack. So for example
this is taking again the example of uh
Alameo R1 from Nvidia which is an
autonomous driving uh reasoning VLA
model. We are basically seeing how for
each of these stages we have different
algorithms that are going on. So we will
have at a high level this is a model
that uses kind of vision language models
in order to compute actions for the car.
So there is a general pre-training phase
that happens and this is kind of
internet scale pre-training. So just
supervised learning. Then we will have
some SFT or supervised fine-tuning which
is basically imitation learning. And
then we'll have a final stage where we
use reinforcement learning to either
align the performance with human
understanding and human values but also
just to squeeze out the last bit of
performance. And so I think it's really
important that you see these tools as
different elements that all together
build up for for autonomy stacks.
Great. Any any questions?
Okay, then see you on on Monday.